un peu de sens de l'État un peu de
dignité un peu de respect pour la
démocratie et un peu de respect pour la
sécurité les institutions canadiennes le
Premier ministre doit dire à Monsieur
Johnson d'aller faire autre chose et
donner mandat ou permettre à la chambre
de désigner quelqu'un pour mettre en
place une véritable en cahier de public
le chef du Bloc québécois qui résume
assez bien le sentiment de plusieurs
élus la semaine dernière après
l'adoption de la motion du NPI demandant
à David Johnston de quitter ses
fonctions juste un Trudeau lui a
continué de le défendre accusant
l'opposition de faire de la petite
politique dans ce dossier alors ou en
sommes-nous maintenant voyons voir ce
qu'on pense mes collaborateurs les
castonguettes animateurs de midi info et
il se première
chroniqueur au tonton de l'actualité et
Michel CEG est analyste politique à
Radio-Canada et à la presse bonjour à
vous trois
bonjour Alec qu'est-ce que la motion
d'une [__] à changer cette semaine
qu'est-ce que ça a fait que des élus
disent oui il devrait partir mais il est
pas parti
c'est quand même les élus de tous les
partis à la Chambre des communes sauf le
Parti libéral donc c'est quand même
quatre parties politiques on inclut le
Parti vert là-dedans qui disent ne pas
avoir confiance en l'homme qui
normalement devrait nous éclairer sur la
voie à suivre pour que la démocratie
canadienne soit plus en santé est-ce que
véritablement monsieur Johnston est si
près des libéraux que ça de Justin
Trudeau de sa famille moi j'en suis pas
convaincu on n'a pas de preuve à cet
effet-là non plus
tu regardes les sondages dans la
population la population non plus n'est
pas convaincue que c'est ça le plus gros
problème le plus gros problème il est
que lorsqu'il va remettre son deuxième
rapport qui va être donc des
recommandations importantes pour
protéger le Canada contre l'ingérence
étrangère la majorité des députés au
Parlement ne vont pas écouter ce qu'il a
à dire ne va pas vouloir collaborer à sa
mise en place et là c'est un problème
c'est qu'à quoi ça sert de le faire
travailler pour rien pendant les
prochains mois qui va vouloir se
présenter aux audiences quel type de
travail va fournir est-ce que ce sera
utile si déjà je sais que quatre des
cinq parties la Chambre des communes ne
veulent rien savoir de cet homme-là
alors là c'est pas très constructif là
c'est pas très pratique transpartisan
comme on peut dire et donc quand il y a
une question de la démocratie canadienne
on essaie d'avoir un minimum de
consensus on a pas ce minimum de
conseils alors c'est un problème
quand même
[Musique]
de minoritaire ce gouvernement peut pas
dire je travaille pour les Canadiens
c'est la fin du gouvernement et on s'en
va en campagne électorale quand quatre
parties votent un vote de non confiance
envers l'homme qui est censé restaurer
la confiance dans le processus électoral
la seule chose à faire c'est et c'est
même pas parce qu'il faut croire que est
en conflit d'intégrer aussi bien
l'empêchent de penser clairement c'est
que le message ou le messager maintenant
ne pas la crédibilité nécessaire pour
accomplir sa mission et quatre parties
qui ont parlé ça a quand même un sens
c'est ça qui est arrivé cette semaine
donc quelqu'un qui a été gouverneur
général est-ce qu'il faut comprendre que
gouverneur général de Steven un peu s'il
y avait eu un vote de non confiance
envers le gouvernement minoritaire
monsieur Johnson aurait dit c'est pas
grave je respecte l'opinion des communes
mais je maintiens une gouvernement
évidemment pas alors c'est quand même
étonnant de le voir dire merci pour
votre opinion mais moi je travaille pas
pour vous c'est ça j'allais dire Michel
ça vous a surpris la réponse de Monsieur
Johnston parce que elle d'abord elle est
sortie très rapidement après le vote et
c'était l'essentiellement je vous ai
écouté mais je vous ai entendu mais je
ne vous écoute pas
moi je ne suis pas venu je suis convenu
encore
quelqu'un qui a déjà fait partie au plus
hauts de l'appareil gouvernemental
canadien le chef d'État général
dit la Chambre des Communes a une
opinion
je travaille pour le gouvernement qui
m'a donné un mandat écoutez je Chantal
le 19
ça n'a pas de sens et c'est un peu
pour quelqu'un qui a signé toute service
client de ne pas ça mal finir de
gymnastique parce que
c'est pas juste une opinion la Chambre
des communes quatre parties qui la donne
ensemble il peut plus continuer
c'est recommandations seront considérées
comme étant
venu je sais pas pourquoi mais je suis
Trudeau ne comprend pas qu'il doit
demander à Johnson mais je pense qu'il
semblait pas fini parce que c'est
tellement inusité
c'est presque la science-fiction
politique j'interest le NPD aurait dû
aller plus loin parce que là la motion
d'une [__] l'ont déposé le long gagné
mais il a pas voulu dire ils sont pas
allés jusqu'à dire on pourrait remettre
en question la survie du gouvernement
bon d'une part j'ai l'impression que le
MPD a fonctionné là-dessus de la même
façon que nous c'est à dire
que tout le monde s'attendait à ce que
Monsieur Johnson prenne acte du résultat
qui était prévu d'avance ou que Monsieur
Trudeau en prenant et le signifient
David Johnson parce qu'on parle toujours
de David Johnson il est pas tout seul
là-dedans si le premier ministre lui
avait dit on pense que c'est intenable
et on veut pas vous soumettre à ça
j'imagine qu'il serait parti il
cherchait pas une emploi ou une raison
d'être dans la vie David
mais sur l'idée qu'on devrait faire
tomber le gouvernement là-dessus la
semaine dernière dans les circonstances
et les attentes de la semaine dernière
pas nécessairement le MPD
et le parti dans les les sympathisants
sont les plus partagées sur cette
idée-là de précipiter du Canada en
campagne électorale il y a quelqu'un qui
disait finalement le plan dentaire est
plus important pour Jack meeting que le
dossier de l'ingérence chinoise
sérieusement il est probablement pas le
seul pour qui le plan de soins dentaire
est plus important effectivement et à
travers tout ça cette semaine on a vu
des débats particulièrement au lieu à la
Chambre des communes beaucoup autour de
la question de l'ingérence mais là ça
fait quelques semaines que le ton monte
de façon assez importante je vais vous
faire entendre quelques extraits qu'on a
recueilli cette semaine puis je vais
vous entendre là-dessus après
[Musique]
public c'est parce qu'il n'a plus
personne qui est membre la Fondation
troudeau pour le faire on a assez déjà
en masse pour demander un enquête
vraiment indépendant public Polynésie
son chum monsieur le Président
en mars mais la réalité monsieur le
Président c'est qu'il ne le sait pas
[Musique]
le chef du Bloc québécois
on n'a pas le niveau de
on a un niveau de fatigue différent de
celui que quand on est revenu de la
période de période des fêtes avec est-ce
que c'est simplement à cause de la
question de l'ingérence étrangère que le
tombeau comme ça où
la courbe on la voyait un bouton
on sent que il commence à être amené de
se voir l'un et l'autre c'est toujours
un peu plus échevé mais là clairement là
il y a quelque chose qui qui est
intéressant qui s'est passé cette
semaine d'abord je pense que Pierre
Pollier avait eu François Blanchet vous
venez d'entendre sont assez vulnérables
lorsqu'on leur dit vous parlez mais vous
n'avez pas vous parlez plus en
connaissance de cause parce que vous
aviez le loisir de lire l'annexe secret
de David Johnston pour savoir ce qu'il
avait découvert et vous avez préféré ne
pas aller la lire contrairement à Jack
meeting et contrairement à un auto par
exemple qui lui a eu un brefage c'est
reste l'ancien chef conservateur sur les
manœuvres qui le visait lui la formation
politique lors des dernières élections
qui a fait un discours très éloquant à
la Chambre des communes où il a réussi à
plaider pour une enquête publique sans
dévoiler tous les secrets que le sars
lui avait dit pourquoi Pierre poi lièvre
n'en fait pas autant pourquoi il
François Blanchet n'en font pas autant
alors là il parle à la Chambre des
communes il a quelque chose qu'on se dit
c'est ouais mais est-ce qu'ils savent
vraiment de quoi il parle ou il préfère
au contraire faire de la petite
politique partisane parce que ça fait
leur affaire ça c'est la première chose
et la deuxième c'est que bon c'est plus
compliqué effectivement de pour les
parties d'opposition de plaider
lorsqu'on est rendu au bout un peu des
arguments mais dans le cas du Justin
Trudeau on regarde les chiffres dernier
sondage ça ne nuit pas tant que ça au
Parti libéral on est toujours au cours
de la coude avec le Parti conservateur
alors peut-être que dans le fond il y a
des libéraux qui se disent à force de
parler d'ingérence on ne parle pas par
exemple de crise du logement on ne parle
pas d'inflation on ne parle pas de ce
qui préoccupe particulièrement les gens
et peut-être que ça dessert aussi les
parties d'opposition jusqu'à un certain
point je dis pas qu'il garde les vieux
Johnston pour ça mais je me dis
peut-être qu'il se dit c'est pas aussi
dommageable que les parties d'opposition
le pensent malgré tous les parages qui
font à la période de questions vous avez
eu quelques vachement de tête à vos
commentaires je commence par Michel puis
Chantal ensuite
d'abord la première chose qu'avec la
plus importante rendue au mois de juin
et que puis-je voir la face et c'est
toujours difficile dans tous les
parlements dans tous les
il y a effectivement là une crise qui va
au cas de la démocratie canadienne et
c'est pour ça que je pense que bon
évidemment les gens se battent pas sur
les dans les autobus sur cette question
là mais se faire dire que une puissance
étrangère qui est intéressée par nos
élections au point d'essayer de siérer
ça les gens savent ce que ça veut dire
aiment pas entendre parler de ces choses
là donc c'est suivi cette histoire là et
les et tous les parties essaient de de
tirer leur couvercle
mes collègues moi je pense pas que les
chute de position qui se créent à
segmenté pour aller lire le document
aurait les mains libres après il y a pas
beaucoup de serments possibles ça
sincèrement discrétion puis ça va le
rester mais à la fin il y a un problème
il y a un problème avec la crédibilité
du rapporteur spécial et tant que ça ce
sera pas évacué il n'y a pas grand chose
qui va pouvoir faire avancer sur le
commentaire effectivement
d'aller voir les documents progrès parce
que les chefs de position disent on va
avoir les mains liés après ça mais on a
entendu surtout cette semaine il y a
quand même été assez éloquant pour
quelqu'un qui était tenu au secret bon
une série de choses là-bas je pense que
Justin Trudeau et puis un poignet vont
pas besoin d'attendre au mois de juin
pour pouvoir se voir l'un l'autre et pas
pouvoir se supporter on est vous avez
raison et le temps de Monsieur poillière
depuis qu'il est chef du Parti
conservateur
est un temps parce que incendiaire je
pense que j'ai pas couvert de shop
l'opposition officielle qui
choisissait délibérément des attaques
aussi personnelles aussi souvent c'est
pas mal son mode d'emploi l'idée d'aller
voir puis de savoir
il y a quelque chose de faux là-dedans
c'est pas parce qu'on voit la même chose
que dès que Johnson quand on est obligé
de dire qu'on arrive à la même
conclusion
il y a pas de serment qui empêche de
dire j'ai vu tout ça et je suis pas
d'accord toujours pas d'accord avec
David Johnson d'une part d'autre part
monsieur auto cette semaine a fait deux
choses d'abord et réussit à marier ses
privilèges par le mental qui sont réels
pour dire des choses à la Chambre des
communes qu'on dirait pas ailleurs et
les liens qui l'empêchaient de dévoiler
des choses qui relèvent de la sécurité
nationale qu'est-ce que ça a donné ça a
donné un discours qui était dévastateur
pour l'argumentaire du gouvernement
parce qu'il parlait en connaissance de
cause mais qui le faisait en situant les
enjeux au niveau de la politique
publique pas au niveau de l'ami de ski
de Justin Trudeau la deuxième chose que
fait en faisant ça c'est qui a fait
assez mal paraître son successeur entre
les deux je dirais que si les libéraux
regardez ce qui se passait et on dû se
dire on a été chanceux que les députés
conservateurs se débarrassent ça donne
autour pour se prendre pierre poilliev
parce que moi je pense je regarde de son
les mêmes sondages qu'avec et je pense
que Pierre poillière contribue
puissamment garder la mise de Justin
Trudeau c'est-à-dire que les gens le
regardent et se disent j'aimerais ça du
changement mais pas celui-là c'est pas
mon genre de changement une force qui
est aussi négative et si c'était un auto
dans les coins sont pas mal moins carré
j'ai l'impression qu'il y a beaucoup
d'électeurs qui seraient finalement il
est temps de passer la main et voici un
adulte responsable qui est capable de
prendre en main les affaires du Canada
en tout cas si vous cherchez l'aspirant
Premier ministre dans les discours cette
semaine vous l'avez pas entendu à la
période des questions vous l'avez
entendu dans le discours des reines
autour
le aurait pu offrir comme performance
un peu plus de 2 minutes mais je vais
vous entendre rapidement sur l'élection
alberten le retour de Madame Smith comme
chef élu là elle est première ministre
de l'alberto je commence avec vous avec
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire pour les
relations fédérales provinciales il y a
quand même eu des messages assez si dur
que tu as envoyé cette semaine
je suis pas certain parce que le Parti
conservateur albertin pas très patient
avec ses chefs encore moins lorsqu'elles
font comme dans le code d'agneau Smith
la pire performance du parti voir depuis
1971 le 5 députés seulement de majorité
pour les conservateurs en Alberta c'est
pas un énorme donc patient envers elle
première chose deuxième chose c'est pas
un mandat très fort pour aller affronter
le Premier ministre Justin Trudeau elle
peut bien dire ce qu'elle veut là il va
pas avoir l'impression que soudainement
là toute l'Alberta est derrière Smith
alors ça va ça va mettre la table des
confrontations intéressantes mais en
termes de rapport de force je suis pas
certain que Daniel smithor de cette
élection là avec un avantage il nous
reste une minute 30 secondes Michel 30
secondes
quand on est en Alberto majorité normale
du gouvernement concernateur c'est au
tour de 40e en avoir 5 c'est pas une
très bonne majorité comme la France de
France j'ai dirige j'étais pas au foyer
moi on est mieux d'être riche là ils ont
un pauvre majorité et ça va se ressentir
cela dit essayer de le Canada devant
essayer d'avoir ces sites de réduction
de GRS ça va être bien compris
je suis pas en train de faire une
prédiction sur la prochaine élection
fédérale mais je note néanmoins que les
deux grandes villes de l'Alberta ont
rejoint Montréal Toronto Vancouver à
l'ifacio et on fait de la place à des
parties qui sont pas nécessaire qui sont
pas conservateurs en tout ou en partie
c'est pas bon signe pour le mouvement
conservateur canadien intéressant je
sais pas si ça va se transposer au
Federer on va surveiller ça chers amis
c'était très intéressant de vous
entendre la semaine prochaine on
recommence ça pour l'heure au complet en
personne à part ça merci d'avoir été des
nôtres puis j'ai bien de vous voir en
personne